so it's just starting off with me you
get some lines to rehearse as scientists
because obviously me and Tamra have to
be in unison for this one
so this should be fun here's Tamra she's
ready to be a scientific Tamra look at
these glasses leave ear hooks and
they're really hard to get on what okay
they look like they're really hard to
see through - yeah I do yeah your pupils
are huge it's like I just feel like I'm
constantly crossing my eyes on these and
they catch my eyelashes oh wow
your eyes look so much bigger so cool
they're like hooked on my face oh no Don
you I definitely can't see anything in
them oh man well I guess we'd better get
back to rehearsing or at least trying to
memorize these all know the room is like
a masterpiece of all ya gotta see it
it's it's really good Wow I mean have
you ever heard of the room at least that
what you guys got Rachel as I could
going-away gift yeah we got an egg cuz
she did a scene with one of the actors
so we figure she should probably see the
movie yeah yeah um so that's the first
time I had heard of it but I I need to
watch it yeah it's like hugely funny
yeah I was saying to let her borrow it
cuz it's just such a bizarre experience
yeah yeah go ahead little tell you get
behind camera there all right let's
getting framed up yeah I guess I still
gotta sit this up so if you like you
feelin
those specs I was saying those specs
make her eyes look huge
well what those are my dad used to used
to be a band and he used to do a Sousa
concert and he would get dressed up as
John Philip Sousa oh and so those are
the glassy oh that's so cool oh so take
comfort knowing that you look like a 60
year old man I I didn't realize until I
think last time we filmed that your dad
could play instruments so well yeah well
he can at least do the piano um
everything else I think he can kind of
do yeah he's familiar yeah yeah he's
he's a composer conductor Aereo the
orchestrator all that stuff he said even
told me if I ever needed audition piano
help yeah he's definitely very good at
the very good of the piano nice um
Malcolm go ahead sort of like as I lean
on the chair like mmm I'm leaning over
the channel as you can see okay Tamra do
some of your fake typing just spamming
on the keyboard
- Bryson um I'll probably will go
through right now tell you what not to
okay keyboard cat also something there's
one of those like classic movie mistakes
and one of them is whenever people type
they never use the spacebar oh my gosh
that's hilarious very accurate
now the orchestrating of this like as I
want you to very much in unison so we
have well according to our research food
fighting on your typing oh the food
fight is said to be one of the worst if
not the worst anime film of all time
and then I'll be the light II you mean
worse like worse worse till I came out
let's hear that seem to be growing
globally as you're presently practice
great and I I think sort of like turn
and start look up like this and you say
the next line so you know if our data
serves correctly did you let me do that
with him yeah exactly that's a yes he's
tops at the stop typing and edition huh
it's like I'm holding a camera with a
camera huh oh yes
so yeah so after after she says
following a surprisingly rapid rate both
you sort of turn and see if you can
rather than just you know have the hand
go like this if you can this circle like
yeah that's good are we looking uh
pretty much uh look at that thing am i
witnessed yeah that's that's not bad
good so do you want to use a surprising
rapid rate yeah and and just before the
finger hits the chin that's when you
start your next line Malcolm if I did
that serves correctly if our data serves
correctly
yeah that's good surprisingly rapid
we're rate so right after raid yeah you
stop typing just go right there sure
yeah Chris this fuckin beam ah could be
as popular as the room and Birdemic
combined could easily be the next big
thing are we still looking like we're
gonna be looking up that whole line yeah
hopefully they'll fit wow they're almost
there I believe in you stay out there
stretching I mean I used to think they
forgot it ish kinda
they disfigure the plaid made them
disfigured it looks okay on that looks
okay the camera said okay so that's good
yes can you do one more one more
sssst for the ultimate proud this is a
joke like we didn't absolutely need but
I just thought I was kind of flying cuz
the the character in the movie where's
all these like sexy outfits and well
that's like a schoolgirl the Britney
Spears outfit pretty much and but with
Izzie's long-planned gloves and they
look really weird because like hey I
never see him before and I know they
don't exist cuz when I tried to find
some to order for this
nothing's is cuz they're ridiculous
looking and I've happened that the hand
always looks like it's on backwards
because it's an optical illusion so it's
just constantly weird it's I it's a
weird thing to fixate on because the
rest movie is so terrible and weird but
it's like it just really struck me as
odd this is one of those bizarre thing
yeah didn't mean to be gym is the best
prop guy though oh yeah Jim made these
from scratch because what we have we had
this other pair that's like we're gonna
use them from frozen but they didn't
look good so it's like okay well time
for something else at like oh I told you
just like paint them wet if that's
possible I don't know if you can't do it
it's not a huge joke so don't worry
about it
and he made these I think he made a mob
as sure cuz I saw like a plaid shirt
back there yeah so okay yeah I think
that works
nice pinkies up that's the biggest
speaker is the longest finger okay yeah
he's right uh first of all she's ever
made yeah definitely not criticizing Jim
very amazing well and they're like the
exact we're coming to like that's what
they look like pretty much Wow
you can we did that looked a little
better sister hole I'll be the mace bug
picture
definitely take a picture yes this is
the nostalgia critic in his natural
habitat
God's hammer is going MC creepy would
mean me you love you Tamra yes I don't
she says like one line wrong she's oh
that guy secrets you discovered that
yeah yeah like you don't talk smack
about you is like oh should they say
right so much fun so what this is gonna
be is that I'm out there and I fee and I
see something it's going to transition
to here as I'm saying this I so like
what's food fight and it's gonna catch
it here why does everybody want me to
review it wow that was a transition
because I am almost never off yeah
that's true that's the house food fight
and why does everybody want to do it
according to our research is that when
you're wearing the lab coat you know you
kind of look like you're studying you
know when you sit nostalgic reggae is
natural habitat hmm what will he do now
oh that's way oh that's what this is it
what the hell is food fight why does
everybody want me to review it so bad
what the hell does food fight why does
everybody want me to review it he does
multiple takes yes what the hell is food
fight why does everybody want me to
review it each one for safety
makes it much easier on the editor
what's something I dunno cuz I'll do I
will do a lot of takes man like half the
time it's um when I do a lot of takes
like it's almost always either the very
first one at the very last one it's very
really one of the ones in between Oh
interesting
so because it's either like the very
natural reaction or no that's not how
one to here let's try it until it sounds
like what I want to hear but then
sometimes the natural one is like oh
shit that was addressed yeah but lots of
options is good too
yeah no no whenever I asked him uh
descendent Academy or something like
that like he'll do like a bajillion
takes which is really good yes if you're
not there to direct them cuz that way
it's like you know let's you can do one
like less or you can do one like this or
you can do one like this I mean there's
so many different ways so it's like it's
it's great for an editor nice so
interestingly he's living so close now
yeah I know they're all migrating up
here right like ya know uh
all right pretty close but I think
Allison's moving the creek migration
moving yeah room I got a guy this is
migration to Chicago to the Midwest
Midwest is the best we're all gonna be
at anime Midwest yeah they might be
awesome be fun this movie sounds insane
yeah it really fucking is it's it's
awful this is so bad
what is the premise like what are the
all the food's doing Brand X is gonna
take over the supermarket which I guess
when the lights go out or sometimes it
doesn't I don't know it's like something
there's a whole magical world of product
placements that suddenly exists and it's
like a town but they could somehow leave
the product placement to go into the
grocery store which does make sense like
sometimes it's a store sometimes it's a
village it makes no sense and they're
trying to stop Brand X from making all
their products plain and boring yeah
yeah isn't that just mmm what we'll have
but I always shop generic right this is
a sense you're saving exactly rev up hmm
and action
hello madam can I interest you in my
product it's called evil poison bites
death no way the point of view shot is
gonna be scary scary
I just okay
I think what I might do I might go like
this I am the villain yes as Chris
Malloy doing the voice oh really yeah
hello madam can i and Russia on next
whoa it's bad it's bad okay ready
Malcolm action hello madam can I
interest you in my product it's called
evil poison bites death oh I'm sorry
that doesn't sound like a product I'd be
interested in
Craig Scott like literally about this is
what you want to get and you're gonna be
moving it's gonna be her point of view
so I'm looking up and just sort of maybe
just little movements like this that's
sort of yeah just soar like a very
gentle rocket I'm gonna be moving like a
a madman like but yeah but yeah pretty
much is keeping that going the whole
time so your height would be right about
here yeah yeah it's a pretty low as well
so so happy fine if you wanna make her a
much give me Ken
I am NOT chicken mm-hmm follow the
yellow brick road
you're still what is there one that's
still alive I don't know I know they
always go to Hollywood no the movie
theater around there because like
they've just happened there
it's not look like Alice I think I've
hit someone in every episode not that
not the Disney Afternoon
but what someone was being it someone
was being hit people don't we've all
been like blown up or beat down an
episode oh yeah we all get evenly
destroyed oh yes I'm trying to think oh
if you got your comeuppance yet the more
I think about it like every does
necessary she gets like she was he
you shot me and burned me in the same
well oh yeah burning or Sarah
yeah that's shot me long as somebody I
love I love a shower you can just be
like oh yeah I shot you living the dream
how much was that toy too much no cuz I
saw one is like this one's on clearance
for only $10 I'm like should be more
than $10 but whatever and I grabbed it
it turns out it was like this different
it doesn't meet the battery said like it
all yo you guys get double a barrier
okay oh they also need double-a
batteries okay I love it that shit
instead of candy Toys R Us the checkout
lines are just full of batteries they do
have like a ton wine yeah I what I mean
you're never gonna use it yeah I can't
see myself using
yeah no I don't think so what about the
baby I gave it to Jim just do it a
million times until you get the cat
racist you're so cool
good job now go Michael Jackson says Oh
that'd be cool to have like a little
sound board of Michael Jackson yeah like
oh yeah Michael Jackson this size Noah
says hey this size knows goes just
higher and higher yeah yeah be able to
see what looks like why don't you I
think you are actually other can do cuz
you're like the director of this I
thought forecast setting off ok and this
is why I am only doing one take of this
this is some nice bit of abstract art uh
this is a Pollock ah so as I like to
call it okay big blob of milk like right
on the corner of my eye
some of my pans looted yes yes god it's
beautiful it is odd that what the cells
these four features Milka is bigger he
is like in the skim milk go to your I
should wash it for a little bit actually
we probably should get a shot of this
just for the crazy uh you're gonna get
some get some fun Bassett can you flail
around in the background for a second um
over here
Oh like a wind-up
Oh
Wow wait that hair trimmer oh my God
look at all the junk food you actually
eat this stuff no there there was
masters and ghouls I heard a voice a zoo
well
oh there's certainly many monsters in
there yes it's a pariah
except for high fructose corn syrup sue
brown sugar is the best kind of the
earth as you can get who let that be
great you've Kozar was just a huge
advertising publicity stunt that would
be incredible like the great has ever
done for Stay Puft Marshmallow x' so yes
zoo advertises Stay Puft Marshmallow x'
yes then what is this the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man advertising himself by
me free samples I blow up you all get at
a stop Hey
so I asked Doug because I know this is
gonna be done with with trick
photography really so the time what CG
items falling on the ground
that's CG items I thought I don't know
what I thought but I'm like so you're
really gonna smash the cans of tuna and
we're the open the Hawaiian Punch and
the the Twinkies can we at least save a
Twinkie and I think the most offensive
besides the tunas also be jar of pickles
so he's literally gonna smash all this
shit and I'm like it and you're gonna do
this on when I presume he's like yeah
and that is why I am sitting on this
chair i standing on this chair well out
of range it would be great I'm taking a
picture of it'll be abstract art they'll
sell millions of dollars if it'd
probably peel it with the product laser
net and stuff it's like some sort of
hope yeah but you'd have to smash it on
something you can't dig up this floor
can't I know
No they'll add even more character yeah
I uh I can't believe you're doing this I
can't date it that's a yeah and you're
gonna clean this up
uh that's what wives are for no ma no ah
did you hear that yeah I think your wife
would best fuck that shit
yeah she says all the time before she
cleans it up I let her have her little
Ono's and stuff but she does it all
right so all you fangirls who want to
hear it does I go were supposed to I
hope you're getting a good whipping
I'll just say if I eat my Twinkies and
so stink male chauvinism I'll put my
feet on her bag she's fancy faux fur Oh
like the horse did you out oh whoa it oh
yeah
taken Oh God now cuz I don't know I'm
just gonna get up on this thing now
fuckin vent ice oh my god Oh sound if I
could make my head - oh great I got a
concussion from this I even get hit with
the frying pan all right what else I'm
gonna lie down in the middle of it No
yes why cuz I love my audience and I
hate this suit I wanted to pay and
suffer bad suit why why do you hate this
suit I don't either this is at you my
stunt suit cuz this one is gonna need
some major drag cleaning hey I know this
was probably gonna be done after this
all right so what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
just lie in the middle of it you can do
sort of like a close-up and you're just
gonna pan away as I'm crying like oh
okay on top of here and just sort of by
me like I'm not walking in this shit
this is gonna be a zoom out
no no just yes this is like
here you're not gonna be in it like
close-up images you just slowly back
away like as far as possible
fine get your ass down there come back
always like that
yeah look at your back turn around oh my
god I think that's that's Twinkie pickle
Hawaiian Punch tuna juice
it looks like Reagan's suit from The
Exorcist like she just took her that
what's been going on I always say one
more time turn around turn around let's
see that's a Jackson Pollock for you oh
wait I think that's Indonesia oh wait
now that looks like a broken away
California okay just say it's Jesus we
all oppressed that way um maybe they're
your the yeah I think I see some Jesus
going on and why Jesus or more like
yellow red white Jesus I think he's a
Jesus a Native American I don't know is
like the greatest portrait of Jesus cuz
he's all colors and he's everything to
everyone and some would I refuse to
believe you of Jesus on your suit and
some would argue a big mess was born
because of interpretations of him so
this is a theology done came from that
well faith does come from the strangest
places huh yeah Jesus
what here you go wrapping you you earned
it
damn straight